we're going to go to that next what is
a woman
what is a woman
it's a good question it's a fair
question i don't know if you've seen a
lot of talk recently about this
documentary that matt walsh
put out there from the daily wire i saw
it i watched it
i think it's important to watch no
matter where you stand on the issue you
may disagree with matt
i don't know matt personally you may
love him you may hate him whatever your
opinion on him is
doesn't matter i think he would say the
same doesn't matter i think it's
important to watch it because it's
eye-opening
and what a documentary is supposed to do
is it's supposed to make you think it's
supposed to provide you with information
ask important questions
interview people and leave you thinking
about an issue no matter where you stand
and that's what it did for me um so i
encourage people to go and watch it even
if you even if you dislike the premise
which is that you know where matt stands
on these issues and i'm not gonna you
know speak for him you can go and check
out where he stands he's not here to
represent his own thoughts so i don't
want to
um
but
what's interesting that happened was
is that you know in the film he
interviews a whole bunch of people he
tries to get to the bottom of the very
simple question what is a woman if
you're talking about you know the
ability of a biological man to become a
woman what is a woman what is the
defining characteristic can you tell me
what that is you get to the end of the
film and no one has been able to answer
that no one who is suggesting that yes a
biological man can become a woman is
able to answer that in fact there's a
lot of defensive why are you asking
there's a lot of that that goes on
parts of it are funny and whatnot what i
thought was interesting about it is that
and i didn't agree with everything in
there there were some things that i said
well i don't know if i would have
executed it that way or
as a living thinking breathing free
thinking human you're gonna watch
something you're gonna have your own
perspective that you come out that's the
whole point that's what they desired
i look at rolling stone
which i don't read but came in my
twitter feed someone retweeted it and i
see this column just a few days later
why are social media companies taking ad
money from a right-wing transphobic doc
i was like okay here we go
if you go in into this article first of
all
they call it hateful
i didn't find it hateful i didn't find
him hateful of these individuals that
was not my perspective at all also
remember transphobic is that the
appropriate word to use you know is
there a deep dislike is there a hatred
of trans people that comes across in
this film you'll have to make the judge
judgment for yourself i didn't find that
either
you have to be able to ask questions the
question is what what is a woman answer
it just answer it give your answer give
your perspective that was the whole
nature of this let's get to the bottom
of what we're really talking about here
you read the article from rolling stone
and it says this
the daily wire has bought ads on major
social media platforms like tick tock
facebook and instagram to promote the
film and so far even though the
documentary seems to violate tick tock
and meta's policies against hate speech
they
the ads stay up
so they're mad about this
they're upset this was an effort
obviously to demonetize
to deep platform
to rally you know the woke cause to say
i don't care if you've seen it this is
the talking point of the day this is
transphobic we have to deploy this is
this is gaining too much traction this
is making too many people think for
themselves about this issue this is
presenting an alternate view that we
don't want out there
it's not a becoming look for the cause
that we value and appreciate we don't
like it imagine if people did this for
every documentary you'd never see
anything you never learn anything you'd
never think you'd have a whole segment
of you'd have the whole population
actually that would be unable to think
which is what they want to say that's
the point right that's the point a
nation of robots
little robots little puppets very 1984.
very 1984 very 1984 and they love it
they love it the less you can think for
yourself the happier they are
so the daily wire responded i was kind
of interested i was like i wonder if
they watch the film you know
that was my first thought did they watch
it
turns out no the daily wire responded uh
this is from the daily wire we have the
receipts rolling stone hit piece calls
what is the woman transphobic but its
author watched
zero percent of the movie
zero percent
if you dig into that column it says that
the daily wire invited the authors the
article's author
moises mendez ii i don't know if i'm
saying that correct moises probably if
he's i'm not sure to watch the
documentary earlier this week and mendes
watched zero percent of the film before
reaching his conclusion and locked his
twitter account after we was called out
that's my favorite part
and then if you go on elizabeth garber
paul the editor of rolling stone's hit
piece managed to sit through a whole 11
percent of the film before she greenlit
the article so they didn't watch it
they didn't watch it so that tells you
everything that you need to know if your
goal
was to
take down the film
in a smart intellectual
way if you really felt like i'm on the
right side of this issue and i need to
show why this is wrong
i'm pretty sure the folks at the daily
wire would have loved that exchange of
ideas that's why he did the documentary
he wanted that conversation
you may not think he did but he did he
wanted that conversation and he would
have had it on film had those people
answer the questions
they didn't want these people who wrote
this article
they didn't want to have an intellectual
debate about this they didn't or they
would have watched the movie they would
have piece by piece what i would do is i
would watch the film and i would go down
this is wrong take notes and then come
out with a really great article that
refutes why
these things are wrong it says you know
this is wrong because of this this is
wrong because of this that's not there
this is just like oh it's transphobic
end of story
it's transphobic and it needs to be shut
down
so that's lazy
it's boring
it's predictable
it's transparent you're showing your
true colors that you didn't you didn't
care
you didn't care to watch it so people
out there if you're going to criticize
something my rule is always you can
criticize whatever you want
you can have a problem with whatever you
want you can disagree with whatever you
want you may watch this movie you may
take my advice go home watch the movie
tonight and say jed write me a comment
and say i hated it and here's why okay
fully entitled to that perspective but
you're not entitled to not watch it and
then pretend you watched it and come out
with a talking point that a whole bunch
of people wrote that you then
disseminate through media and all the
little robots in the stafford wife movie
follow through like little robots and
they repeat it and regurgitate it and
we're somehow supposed to take you
seriously
no you have to earn that you have to
earn the right to be taken seriously
this is not a serious piece
and i think you know this topic of
gender we're going to dig into this um
not fully today because i want to have
some guests on and a lot of you have
been asking about guests the guests are
coming there's some infrastructure that
needs to be in place for the guests
because i am not shying away from
controversy
so let's just say that we need some
infrastructure
but um
we're going to bring some guests on some
key guests and we're going to talk about
this gender issue it's an important
issue
and it's it's a valid question right
it's a valid question what is a woman
what is a man these are just important
questions you can have many different
answers to those questions but it's
important that we that we ask them and
that we're okay with having a discussion
about what's going on
one of the topics that's kind of come
off of this and been really really
important is
women's sports
and what's going to happen to women's
sports you've seen a lot of coverage of
leah thomas
um the transgender swimmer who's been
winning
um beating out biological women
very controversial
i saw an article in the post-millennial
also over the weekend
that
says biological males win women's
cycling event kiss while third place
female they mean the biological female
cares for child
if you look into the article and read
through that a little bit it says emily
bridges and lily chant two biological
men who identify as transgender won the
first and second place slots at london's
thundercrit cycling event on thursday
and you can flip through the third place
went to the only biological woman in the
photo she's pictured holding her child
and standing you can see the picture
it'll show you can read on if you want
to read these articles so this is this
is a legitimate topic of discussion
that's her she's holding her little girl
i don't know if they were on a platform
i don't know what's going on there that
created that dynamic
i don't know
this is a legitimate topic this is a
fair topic
i am a female
i'm athletic i didn't really get
involved in competitive sports i ran
track in high school
a little bit
more to clear my head than anything i
wasn't that competitive about it but i
had a lot of friends that worked their
butts off
their whole lives really wanted sports
scholarships a good friend of mine in
college was on a basketball scholarship
and they want it they had aspirations of
professional
sports um
that was their their dream
it's a worthwhile discussion to have in
terms of what happens to women's sports
if
biological men
that
transition
and you know define themselves as women
are now able to to play in women's
sports what happens to the biological
women they're they're going to be at a
disadvantage
they are going to be at a disadvantage
what do we do how do we deal with what's
happening right now and i think it's
fair to say
that someone
someone
should ask these questions for the women
that work their whole lives these since
little girl some some women works from
their little kids you know training for
these things this is their lifelong
dream these are fair questions
legitimate questions again
and i'm always curious when these
conversations happen where the feminists
are
because what i see is is a heavy
reluctance to defend
women
to say
this isn't fair
what happens if we wind up in a world
where there are
men sports and transgender sports
and the women get boxed out
completely it could happen it could
happen what are women going to be third
and fourth and fifth place
what happens if they can't get that
first and second place spot what what
what is going to happen here
for women who want to play sports and
that's their passion and that's their
love and that's their dream
where are the feminists
and
i've always had a problem with people
who call themselves feminists very often
times anyway because it seems like
they're not advocates for women it seems
like they're advocates for a liberal
cause
and if the actual well-being of women
needs to take a back seat it will every
single time in the same way
that
gloria steinem used to be you know
outspoken for women but then she would
hold hands and chat with bill clinton
all the time you know the womanizer and
be like oh bill oh bill you know
it seems very selective
it seems very selective
so
i think it's a fair question again to
ask where this is all going
what's going to happen and where are the
people that are supposed to be advocates
for women and if they're silent why are
they silent
why are they silent why is no one taking
a minute to think about the other side
of this issue are they afraid is
everyone afraid now
everyone's afraid to speak up because
you'll be censored you'll be labeled
whatever a bigot this that or the other
i mean no one can just speak and say uh
hold on a second i have a daughter who
plays sports and x y i mean why
don't allow that to happen to the
conversation
don't allow i don't care you get
censored somewhere go somewhere else and
have it
have it at your dinner table with your
you know your friends adults not a
conversation for children necessarily
unless you as an adult decide that it's
a conversation you want to have with say
your teenager who's going through this
i'm talking about little kids
two-year-olds three-year-olds who some
feel should be talking about issues of
sex in schools
not me
so i'm putting that out there as kind of
a tease because we are i find it
horrific um what rolling stone did just
because they didn't watch it and i find
this this refusal to watch a movie
before commenting this refusal to
actually
voice an opinion
because you're afraid you're going to be
labeled something
it's not helping anyone it's not helping
the conversation it's not helping any of
us it's not helping it's not even
helping your cause frankly because the
second you tell someone oh i hated this
movie and i didn't watch it you look
like an idiot
so now no one even wants to hear what
you have to say
now everyone's like oh well they don't
even care about what they're
they're trying to defend or they would
have watched the damn film and they
would have come out with counterpoints
so it doesn't help anyone there's a
bottom line
and we're going to get into this more
that was a tease
and i know there'll be people who say oh
jed don't cover this it's too no
i'm here for the controversy
i'm here for the storm we're in a storm
right
i'm not going to hide i'm gonna get my
umbrella luckily it's dirty not always
sometimes i fly off you know one time an
umbrella in new york city true story
lifted me right off the ground like mary
poppins mary poppins floated right on up
i'm not that lightweight i'm lightweight
but i'm not that lightweight floated
right on off there and i think i put out
a request can someone make an umbrella
that here in florida let's put it out
there
umbrella companies
make an umbrella that doesn't enable me
to be lifted off the ground by a gust of
wind
let's put that out there anyway i'm
built for the storm with a good umbrella
in hand i like to have an umbrella you
need some protection
um
and so we're going to get more into that
in coming so think about what i asked
today think about the questions and
think about how
you may be sitting at home right now and
you may be that person who has an
opinion about something and
hesitates to share it
think about a world in which everyone
sat back and hesitated to share it out
of fear that they would be labeled
something what does that world look like
scary
it's a scary world don't let that happen
to this country i don't care what the
issue is at hand well real quick back
towards sports do you remember uh back
in 2020 the transgender mma fighter yes
broke a woman's skull yeah yeah and now
a couple months ago california uh
reported they had
pregnant female inmates because they
were housing them with the transgender
females it's to your point where does
this go like where are the people that
want to stand up for women and protect
women this is absurd so and right you're
talking about prison just broaden
broaden it out and say you know it
started as a conversation i think about
kids bathrooms
in north carolina yep and now it's it's
broadened out so just think about
everything has a slippery slope right so
just think about where and i've learned
to do this more because i used to be
someone who really dealt with what was
happening let's deal with the now but
the now becomes the later
and what's happening now is that it's
becoming the later faster than ever
before it seems so just think about all
of those things and all the different
areas of life but more than anything i'm
always saying think about a world in
which
you decide to stay silent because you
don't want to be controversial and what
happens then
you have to re conversation is sometimes
resistance it's you saying that doesn't
sound right to me here's why you have to
have a voice you must have a voice this
is not a time i always say this is not a
time for cowards and it's not not on
this issue not on any issue if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]